s'agissait-il d'un meurtre délibéré ou
d'un tir accidentel c'est ce que doit
déterminer le procès d'André jugé à la
cour d'assis de tour pour le meurtre de
sa femme Ghislaine le 25 avril 2019 à
Cheillé hier ce sont des voisins et la
soeur de l'accusé qui ont été entendus à
la barre faisant le portrait d'un homme
dépassé par la maladie d'Alzheimer de sa
femme mais qui refusait tout aide
aujourd'hui le process s'est concentré
sur l'audition de l'accusé qui lui a
toujours affirmé qu'il s'agissait d'un
accident Léa Turquie était sur place
si je l'avais vu mettre la cartouche
dans le fusil le drame ne serait pas
arrivé ma femme serait encore là des
sanglots dans la voix André 81 ans
replonge dans la journée du 25 avril
2019 le jour où il avoue avoir appuyé
sur la gâchette de son fusil pointé vers
Gislaine sa femme aujourd'hui il
soutient devant la cour qu'il ne savait
pas que l'arme était chargée un discours
contradictoire avec notamment sa
première audition le lendemain du
meurtre alors les débats sont denses on
revient sur des faits extrêmement graves
et donc pour lui c'est revivre aussi des
choses extrêmement difficiles et il faut
arriver à son âge avec l'ancienneté des
faits à pouvoir tout recadrer redire
clairement comment les choses se sont
produites donc c'est pour ça parfois que
ça peut apparaître un petit peu flou un
petit peu compliqué ce 25 avril 2019
André explique retrouver sa femme dans
sa chambre avec un fusil de chasse à la
main tous les deux sont sous l'emprise
de l'alcool il aurait tenté de la
désarmer une dispute éclate de toute
façon t'es pas capable de tirer aurait
et c'est là que le coup se répartit
depuis le début du procès des proches du
couple témoignent devant la Cour sa
famille dépend un couple inséparable
depuis plus de 50 ans de l'autre côté un
voisin par le de violence quotidienne au
sein du foyer en 2016 Ghislaine commence
à montrer des signes de la maladie
d'Alzheimer une maladie additionnée à
une consommation importante d'alcool qui
a pesé de plus en plus sur le quotidien
du couple jusqu'à des actes violents
elle aurait menacé André avec un couteau
je pense que c'était un procès important
pour que mon client puisse s'exprimer et
puisse dire pour lui comment cela s'est
produit après on verra bien ce que les
jurés décideront de se dossier là la
cour d'assise de tour devra trancher
entre l'homicide volontaire ou
involontaire d'ici la fin du procès
mercredi l'accusé en cours la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité